die Idee stammt ja eigentlich aus der
Science-Fiction aber einige namenhafte
Tag personalities halten es tatsächlich
für möglich der Upload eines
menschlichen Bewusstseins in die Cloud
für Ray Kurzweil Erfinder futurist und
director of Engineering bei google
verspricht so ein Upload nichts weniger
als die Unsterblichkeit der Physiker und
ki-experte Max tegmark zählt den Upload
des Bewusstseins zu den möglichen Wegen
zu künstlicher Superintelligenz und auch
ihre Maske will das Gedächtnis in die
Cloud hochladen und Gehirne direkt mit
künstliche Intelligenz verbinden
aber ist das alles wirklich realistisch
nun zufälligerweise haben wir eine
Neurobiologen im Team und seine
Einschätzung ja und warum ja ein genau
das erklären wir jetzt
[Musik]
das Bewusstsein steckt im Gehirn das
funktioniert zwar nicht wie ein
elektronischer Rechner aber forschende
sprechen beim Gehirn oft von einem
Computer weil es eben auch Informationen
verarbeitet außerdem gibt es
funktionierende Schnittstellen zwischen
Gehirn und Computer die beiden Systeme
sind also zu einem gewissen Grad
kompatibel künstliche neuronale
Netzwerke die das Gehirn nachahmen sind
in der Karriereentwicklung äußerst
erfolgreich es gibt zum Beispiel
Computer aus Gehirn und es werden auch
funktionierende Computermodelle von
biologischen neuronalen Netzwerken in
der Forschung verwendet das human brain
project eine Initiative der EU fördert
genau diese Art der Forschung mit einer
Milliarde Euro
das alles erweckt den Eindruck dass man
sein Bewusstsein auf einen Computer
übertragen können müsste aber leider
gibt es da so ein paar kleine
Hindernisse wir gehen davon aus dass das
Bewusstsein eine vom Gehirn erzeugte
subjektive Empfindung von Gedanken
Gefühlen und Sinneswahrnehmungen ist
beeinflusst von Erinnerungen und das
vergisst man leicht auch den
Befindlichkeiten des Körpers all diese
Informationen stecken in den
Verbindungen und aktivitätsmustern des
Nervensystems bestimmte Teile des
Neokortex spielen bei der Empfindung von
Bewusstsein wohl eine entscheidende
Rolle andere Höhengebiete wie zum
Beispiel das Kleinhirn braucht es nicht
um prinzipiell ein Bewusstsein zu haben
aber der Neokortex bekommt seine
Informationen aus dem gesamten Gehirn
auch vom kleinen z.B um eine Person im
Computer zu simulieren muss man also
jedes einzelne Neuron im Gehirn kennen
kann das gehen
[Musik]
durchschnittlich hat ein Mensch 86
Milliarden Neuronen jedes einzelne davon
hat einzigartige chemische und
anatomische Eigenschaften und auch
tausende Verbindungen zu wiederum
anderen Neuronen sie alle ergeben sich
aus dem Genen der körperlichen
Entwicklung und der Lebenserfahrung
einer Person besonders die Verknüpfungen
der Neuronen sind wichtig in der
Neurowissenschaft ist das konnektom zu
kartieren deshalb ein zentrales
Forschungsziel um jedes Detail eines
neurons aufzulösen reichen normale
Mikroskope nicht da braucht man dann
schon Elektronenmikroskope das alan
brian-institut hat ein Stück Maus Gehirn
mit einem Elektronenmikroskop untersucht
die Probe war ein Kubikmillimeter groß
etwa Sandkorn größer darin enthalten
waren rund 100.000 Euro wohnen mit einer
Milliarde Synapsen also
Verbindungsstellen die Probe wurde in
25000 Scheibchen geschnitten das Scannen
dauerte fünf Monate und die Daten füllen
zwei Petabyte Speicherplatz für einen
Kubikmillimeter das menschliche Gehirn
ist durchschnittlich aber rund 1.230
Kubikzentimeter groß also 1,23 Millionen
Mal so groß wie die Probe in der Studie
hochgerechnet würde so ein Scan also
mehr als
512.000 Jahre dauern und 2,5 Setter Byte
oder 2,5 Billionen Gigabyte an Speicher
belegen
hmm na gut aber computing power und
Speicherkapazitäten verdoppeln sich ja
laut dem musischen Gesetz alle zwei
Jahre oder nehmen wir also mal ganz
optimistisch an es bleibt dabei was es
bei the way nicht tut dann dauert es
noch rund 80 Jahre bis wir mit 2,5
Setter Arbeit so umgehen können wie wir
heute mit 2,5 Gigabyte umgehen also in
den Arbeitsspeicher laden und in
Echtzeit verarbeiten sagen wir also in
rund 80 Jahren können wir Routine mäßig
die Daten sollte Elektronenmikroskops
verarbeiten noch ein bisschen
optimistischer und der Scan selbst
dauert dann auch keine 512000 Jahren
das Bleibende Problemchen für ein
Elektronenmikroskop muss das Gehirn
gefriergetrocknet in Scheibchen
geschnitten und in einen Vakuum gebracht
werden wir können also nur ein totes
Gehirn scannen und das ist nicht nur ein
Problem weil man ja eigentlich sein
Bewusstsein als Backup haben will und
eben nicht sterben will sondern auch
weil uns der Scan von totem Gewebe gar
nicht zeigt wie genau die einzelnen
Verbindungen funktionieren das ist aber
wichtige Information denn jede Synapse
ist anders manche lösen Aktionspotenzial
aus andere unterdrücken sie dabei wirken
die einen Synapsen stärker als die
anderen außerdem können sie von Hormonen
und sogenannten Neuromodulatoren
temporär oder sogar permanent verändert
werden auch Gliazellen üben einen
direkten Einfluss auf die Funktion von
Neuronen aus und sie sind genauso
zahlreich das heißt nachdem wir das
Gehirn vermessen haben mit einer
Technologie die wir mit viel Optimismus
in 80 Jahren vielleicht erwarten können
wissen wir immer noch nicht genug um das
Bewusstsein zu simulieren aber um an die
fehlenden information zu kommen gibt es
tatsächlich zwei Wege
der erste Weg ist jedes einzelne Molekül
an jeder einzelnen Synapse zu scannen
ein spezielles Verfahren der
Elektronenmikroskopie erreicht sogar die
entsprechende Auflösung wenn wir auf
diese Weise ein ganzes Gehirn scannen
könnten wir vielleicht die chemischen
Reaktionen an der Synapse simulieren das
heißt wir brauchen noch mehr Daten noch
mehr Vertrauen auf das Moschee gesetzt
und noch mehr Geduld der zweite Weg wäre
die eingangs- und Ausgangssignale von
jedem einzelnen Neuron in jeder
erdenklichen Situation zu messen also
wie reagiert ein bestimmtes Neuron wenn
alle anderen 86 Milliarden - 1 Millionen
ein bestimmtes Aktivitätsmuster bilden
man muss also komplette Gehirne in
Aktion scannen das geht mit Magnet
resonanztomographie MRT dabei müsste man
das Verhalten der Atome des Gehirns in
einem Magnetfeld die bekannten Bilder
von Hirns zeigen meist welche
Hirngebiete aktiver oder weniger aktiv
sind als das Gehirn in Ruhe
aber MRTs sind zu langsam um einzelne
Aktionspotenziale zu messen und die
bisher erhältlichen Geräte können auch
keine einzelnen Neuronen auflösen
geschweige denn Synapsen in Kliniken
haben die MRTs magnetstärken bis zu 7
Tesla und dadurch eine Auflösung von
rund 2,75 Kubikmillimeter ihr erinnert
euch vielleicht ein Kubikmillimeter
enthält eine Billionen Synapsen mehr
Power bis zu 21 Tesla haben zwar einige
MRTs im Forschungslabors da passt aber
meist auch nur eine Maus rein und die
Auflösung ist immer noch zu gering und
schließlich sind MRT ist super
gefährlich weil sie jedes
magnetisierbare Objekt in ein tödliches
Projektil verwandeln können
und da enden die Probleme immer noch
nicht ab einer gewissen magnetstärke
wird die Funktion von Neuronen
beeinflusst der Scan erhitzt das Gehirn
und lebendes Gewebe bewegt sich was das
Scannen besonders kleiner Strukturen
weiter erschwert
vermutlich sind wir in Sachen MRT für
das Scannen von Hirnfunktionen in
lebende Menschen schon heute an den
Grenzen des Machbaren mit dem MRT werden
wir diese Daten also vermutlich nicht
bekommen ganz abgesehen davon dass wir
ja die Neuronen in allen möglichen
Situationen beobachten wollen und eben
nicht nur wenn der Mensch in einer
dröhnenden Röhre liegt
mein Bewusstsein ist in der Cloud
Gefahren mein Körper wurde 100 Jahren
irgendwann mal eingefroren und beim
Auftauen scheinbar irgendwas schief
gegangen aber egal ich schicke dir jetzt
einen Link da klickst du einfach drauf
und
wieso hast du denn nordvpn auf deinem
Handy in der Zukunft alle nordvpn haben
und der Code Doktor Watson immer noch 4
Monate auf ein zwei Jahresabo bringt ich
bin ja nicht blöd denkst du ich verlasse
100 Jahre alten fishingversuch ein
vielleicht überlegt Sie 30 Tage Geld
zurück Garantie dann versuche ich es
einfach noch mal ich kann immer noch
hören
okay wo stehen wir jetzt schon für den
ersten Schritt mussten wir Scanner und
Computertechnologien fantasieren die
eine Billion mal so schnell und
leistungsfähig sind wie heute für den
zweiten Schritt mussten wir dann noch
mal eine Schippe drauflegen um die
Moleküle an den Synapsen zu scannen aber
dabei bleibt es noch nicht denn wir
haben einen Aspekt noch immer nicht
berücksichtigt und das ist die
Plastizität des Gehirns
wenn man sein Bewusstsein hochgeladen
hat so stellt man sich das ja vor lebt
man in einer neuen weltweit weiter die
man erkunden kann man bekommt vielleicht
neue Fähigkeiten kann fliegen trifft
andere Computerwesen und erlebt das ein
oder andere Abenteuer um all das tun zu
können muss das simulierte Gehirn aber
vor allem eins sein lernfähig wie und
was wir schneller oder langsamer lernen
ist Teil unserer Persönlichkeit und auch
das müssen wir also simulieren das
Gehirn lernt in dem sich die einzelnen
Neuronen ganz individuell anpassen und
wie sie das tun ist je nach Neuron
unterschiedlich wieder gibt es zwei
Lösungen um an diese Daten theoretisch
ran zu kommen erstens wir sammeln alle
Informationen über die Anatomie
Aktivität und die Verbindungen aller
Neuronen über einen langen Zeitraum im
lebenden Menschen mit einer Technologie
die man sich eigentlich nur erträumen
kann oder zweitens wir hoffen weiter auf
das Musische Gesetz und eine
fantastische Elektronenmikroskop Scanner
Technologie bis wir eine komplette
Simulation der Gesam Biochemie des
Gehirns durchführen können egal wofür
wir uns entscheiden die Technologien
müssten absolut fehlerlos funktionieren
denn selbst eine geringe Fehlerrate
könnte tiefgreifende Veränderungen am
Bewusstsein einer Person hervorrufen
dieses neu Bewusstsein könnte sogar an
extremen Störungen leiden und am Ende
hoffen wir immer noch dass das
simulierte Bewusstsein den Rest des
Körpers nicht allzu sehr vermisst denn
das Gehirn steht ja eigentlich im
ständigen Austausch mit dem Körper und
braucht diesen Austausch auch ich würde
ehrlich gesagt extrem ungern auf Essen
verzichten selbst wenn ich keinen Hunger
mehr hätte egal wie wir es anstellen um
eine Person unverändert in einer
Simulation aufleben zu lassen brauchen
wir eine
unvorstellbare Menge an Informationen
über das Gehirn und eine unglaubliche
rechenauer aber gut könnte vielleicht
ein Gehirn Computer Interface wie das
von nura Link denn genügend
Informationen sammeln leider auch nein
die elektrodenbasierte Technologie ist
viel zu invasiv denn um die elektrischen
Signale jedes einzeln aufzunehmen müsste
jedes Neuron seine eigene Elektrode
bekommen die in direktem Kontakt mit der
Zellmembran steht und selbst wenn das
technisch möglich wäre wäre das
vermutlich immer noch nicht praktikabel
während das Mosche Gesetz uns vielleicht
noch glauben lassen mag dass wir diese
Menge an Daten irgendwann im 22
jahrhundert handhaben können ist eine
entsprechende scanner-technologie noch
überhaupt nicht in Aussicht wir
bräuchten also Technologien die so weit
fortgeschritten sind dass wir sie von
Magie nicht unterscheiden können kein
Wunder also dass kurz weil den Upload
erst nach der von ihm prophezeiten
Singularität erwartet ein hypothetischer
Zeitpunkt von dem an künstliche
Intelligenz sich selbst immer schneller
verbessert eine Art Intelligenz
Explosion die instantan unglaubliche
Technologien hervorbringen soll die
alles sofort möglich machen
bleibt neugierig euer Cedric